somehow even shows about cannibals and
serial killers can cross a line in the
eyes of fans from animal cruelty to
gruesome deaths of fan favorite
characters these were the TV scenes
disturbing enough to turn people off
from entire series early in its Run The
Walking Dead had some of the most deeply
affecting scenes that TV had ever seen
with children becoming Walkers and loved
ones eating their own kin even so
viewers weren't turned off by the
violence instead they ate it up weakly
and made the series a Bonafide
phenomenon and the start of season 7
however one moment in particular shook
many viewers to their core the season
premiere the day will come when you
won't be saw the horrific conclusion to
the previous season's Cliffhanger in
which the megga maniacal villain Negan
lined up survivors intending to bash
them with his Barbed bat I'm going to
beat the holy hell out of one of you
after smashing Abraham's head to a
bloody pulp he turns his attention to
Glenn and proceeds to slaughter him in a
moment so nausea inducing it sent fans
scurrying as Glenn whimpered Maggie's
name in his final breath as some
redditors observed even the show's many
graphic scenes up to this point Didn't
prepare them for such immense Carnage
with some even claiming they stopped
watching the show all together after the
brutal sequence while starre has had it
share of more adult moments it's usually
being familyfriendly that began to
change when it came back to TV in 2017
with Star Trek discovery which
occasionally earned a TV MA rating in
2020 the longer way sequel Star Trek
Bard pushed the boundaries further and
the fifth episode Stardust City rag went
too far for some viewers the episode
opened with one of the most shocking and
graphic scenes in the franchise's
history as a beloved character from Star
Trek Voyager made his return in a brutal
torture scene taken captive by a
sadistic villain the former Bor drone EB
is strapped down and has his eyeball
plugged out of its socket in full view
of the camera though the scene doesn't
go anywhere other adult dramas haven't
gone before it's affected plenty of
trekkies who didn't expect such a
disturbing and gory moment in what had
ordinarily been a family show as one
parent wrote on Trek movie.com the EB
scene is way over what I want to see and
experience Star Trek is a show I want to
put on and watch with my son without
having fear of sending him to a
psychological doctor centered on the
life of bitter and burdensome father
Frank Gallagher Shameless Stars Emy
rosam as his eldest daughter Fiona with
a mother arranged from the family Fiona
is left to become a mother and caretaker
to her siblings it's not until season 2
that Fiona's real mother Monica is
introduced to the series though she
tries to make up for lost time and be
the mother Fiona never had she can't
overcome her own demons despite her best
efforts it all falls apart in a scene
that has scarred more than one fan of
the series while her family is
celebrating Thanksgiving Monica tries to
take her own life on the kitchen floor
though her boyfriend is able to get help
and save her in time fion was left to
clean up the bloody aftermath the dark
sequence of events upset many viewers
with many Shameless fans on Reddit
acknowledging that the episode forced
them to relive their own experiences
with suicide and other traumas the
handmaid tale is based in a beloved
dystopian sci-fi novel by Margaret
Atwood and has excelled as one of the
more disturbing visions of a dark future
it follows the life of June Osborne a
young woman whose life is turned upside
down when the government enacts a bruel
patriarchal regime that turns women into
slaves overnight filled with social
allegory the series has been critically
acclaimed since it first premiered
but right out of the gate it provided a
scene that has left many extremely
troubled and reluctant to sit through it
more than once on a Reddit thread asking
which TV scenes have Disturbed viewers
the most one user highlighted the very
first scene of the series which depicts
Jun and her daughter Hannah being
kidnapped the agonizing sound of Hannah
Scream cements the scene is historically
horrifying and it makes her later
encounters with her mother all the more
heart-wrenching when it comes to scenes
that hit viewers hardest there are a few
more guilty offenders in the future
armor episode Jurassic Bark if you've
ever watched the show you're almost
certain to agree that the episode's
ending scene is so emotional that even
if you can't bring yourself to rewatch
it it's clear why so many fans can't
bear it the episode sees fry discovering
the filiz remains of his dog Seymour
some thousand years after his pet has
perished the episode ends with Fry's sad
realization that Seymour lived 15 more
years without him and had likely found a
new best friend and forgotten their time
together think about it Seymour lived a
full life after I was gone he probably
even added new songs to his repertoire
if that wasn't he jerking enough the
episode's final scene shows Seymour back
in the past hopelessly waiting on the
sidewalk through rain SLE and snow for
fry to return to his side as a years
pass we see Seymour grow old and die
lost and alone without his beloved best
human friend what it viewers so hard
though is how real life made it all the
more poignant as one reditor observed
the cartoon sequence highlights the fact
that there are many real people out
there who treat their loyal pets poorly
or outright abandon them as important as
is to remember that might not be
something viewers want to tune into a
cartoon to be reminded of the outer
limits is no stranger to unsettling
moments and scenes that send Shivers up
your spine even so despite all the
classic episodes the franchise has
produced there's one moment that is far
more disturbing than the rest and it
comes from an episode of the Revival
series called Simon says the episode
Stars Academy Award winner Joel gray as
an inventor and engineer who hopes to
replace his dead sun with a robot
duplica the problem is that the
resulting creation doesn't have a good
grasp of human morality or its own
dangerous capabilities and soon becomes
a misguided Tormentor as dark as that
concept is on its own the scene where
Simon is innocently petting a cat is
what has fans of the show wishing they
never tuned in oh she never lets me pet
her daddy got it for me but she doesn't
like me sadly while Simon believes he's
casually feeling the kitty soft fur he's
actually mutilating it with a sharp
robot fingers as a radit user pointed
out what's particularly unsettling about
this scene is Simons and canny robotic
mannerisms are what makes a sequence
especially grating to witness skins is a
British drama about a group of teens and
this been applauded by its fans for its
grounded gritty and realistic take on
the life of young people it dealt with
serious issues like sex drugs and mental
health and did so with a refreshing
frankness in the late 2000s that made it
a favorite of many teen viewers however
the show wrote off one of its most
popular characters Freddy McClair in
such a brutal way it left an impact on
many of its loyal fans in the seventh
episode of the show's fourth season
Freddy's girlfriend Effie asks him to
inform a psychiatrist that she no longer
wants to see him after he reveals that
he's in love with her unfortunately
Freddy's visit leads to a fight for his
life and the psychiatrist bludgeons him
to death with a baseball bat so he can
have Fe to himself even though it mostly
happens off screen it's enough to send
viewers into a psychological Tail Spin
as one rdit user wrote that scene will
actually haunt me until the day I die
the scene proves so unnerving that more
than a decade later a professional
reviewer F El magazine wrote an entire
oped about us life-changing effect on
her in 2010 sauris Charlie Brooker
crafted Black Mirror a contemporary
contribution to the genre of sci-fi
anthologies like the Twilight Zone and
the outer limit updated for the 21st
century stories were more focused on
Modern social issues and the dangers of
technology and its first episode
featured a scene so painful to watch
that many decided they never would again
the opening episode involves a prime
minister of Britain being blackmailed
into having sexual intercourse with a
pig to save the life of a royal family
member who has been taken hostage the
scene where the PM goes through with the
ACT might still be the most shocking in
the show's history and some have pointed
out that the decision to kick off the
series with such a disturbing first
installment may be part of the problem
as one Reddit user wrote I heard so many
glowing Raves about the show I decided
to give it a try since it seemed like
something I'd love a year has passed
since I saw episode 1 and I can't bring
myself to even consider watching episode
2 it seems they weren't alone as another
rer to explain that they who knew of
many people who had stopped after that
fateful first episode nevertheless
despite scores of online comments from
viewers had refused to watch another
episode Black Mirror went on to become a
Smash Hit and that harrowing first
episode was followed by 26 more and a
made for streaming movie before actor
Thomas Gibson was booted from Criminal
Minds after an onset altercation with a
producer he played special agent Aaron
Hutch hutner for 12 Seasons at the
outset of the series Hutch is married to
a woman named Haley and the pair
remained close even after their divorce
despite not being together hotch was
left broken when he was forced to listen
to his ex-wife's death and it proved
almost as traumatic for audiences as it
did for him in the episode 100 hotch and
the team are tracking a deadly serial
killer named foyet however the
murderer's next Target is hotch's
ex-wife and the young son and despite
the team's attempts at keeping them safe
foyet takes him prisoner foyet then
calls har and puts him on the phone with
Haley the agent then listens as the
killer puts a bullet through his
ex-wife's head it seems that the visual
setup and portrayal of the the murder
was a disturbingly perfect storm for
viewers with several redditors
commenting that the episode stuck with
them for a long time after their initial
viewing even though it was a comedy Mash
was never afraid to go dark known for
mixing Melancholy themes with black
humor even a show set in the middle of a
bloody war seems to have crossed a line
in the eyes of its viewers what's
particularly impressive about this scene
is that it remains unsettling despite
barely showing anything on screen the
event in question happened during the
show's 2hour series finale goodbye
farewell and amen po Kai Begins the
episode by describing a recent incident
where he helped a bust load of refugees
stay clear of an enemy attack recalling
that he had to tell a woman to silence
her screaming chickens later however we
learned that when the woman had to kill
her cargo to save the entire group of
refugees it was no chicken she held but
her own baby for both Avid Mash fans and
people completely unfamiliar with the
series The episode still left quite an
impact as one Reddit user wrote I never
watched the mash regularly but saw that
episode when I was a kid and still think
about it from time to time
a new adaptation of the tales of serial
killer Hannibal lecta Hannibal made
waves for his visceral Gore and
disturbing images in nearly every
episode it wasn't just bloody violence
either but a nerving Concepts that made
audiences queasy week after week still
there's one scene that went far above
what the series regularly put on screen
and left viewers wishing they'd never
seen it it goes down in the season 2
episode to may vanon but lecta provides
mind-altering drugs to a man in a
deranged game after Lea tells him to
show him how his father would Slaughter
animals on the farm the man begins
slicing off chunks of his own face and
feeding them to his dogs according to
Fan discussions on Reddit well the scene
was enough to horrify some viewers into
giving up on the show completely even
some who stuck it out with the series
thereafter still had a pretty visceral
reaction to the violence from the Red
Wedding to various beheadings HBO's
fantasy epic Game of Thrones is littered
with Gore and other moments that could
easily make this list looking at
reactions from fans across social media
a few have stood out including a scene
from the season 6 episode home like so
many other horrifying moments it
involved the bloody death of a character
but this time it was a double dose of
disturbing as it saw the end of two
innocent lives in a fashion too
uncomfortable for many to sit through in
the episode Ramsey Bolton fears his
father ruse will takeway his inheritance
after his wife gives birth to a new baby
boy to ensure his future Ramsey betrays
them all murdering his father and
feeding Walder and her baby to
Winterfell
hounds he's your brother
I prefer being an only child though we
don't see their deaths firsthand their
blood curling screams and the sound of
ripping flesh of wer and a newborn baby
were enough to send viewers over the
edge as one rdit user put it I remember
this scene but I seriously think I
repressed it a bit I kind of recall some
gruesome noises but I forgot how graphic
it
was